what did you go to NYU for I I was into
NYU film school for film school and I
concentrated I I guess I used to say I
had a concentration in children's TV but
I really I took a couple classes in
children's TV but uh basically I went to
film school and then and so I mean
you've told the story but in a nutshell
who did you bump into first was it
Showalter
or Merino
met me and Todd hollaback and Ken Marino
were um were the in a class ahead we so
we were there as freshmen and Ken Moreno
I met the first day of school because I
was assigned to be roommates with
somebody he grew up with in Long Island
and so my myself and Craig wedron were
living with this guy and Ken Moreno
knocked on our door and he was like this
Italian guy from Long Island they were
like Gotta Love Camp no but we were we
loved him from moment one so we all hang
out and Todd hollaback basically Mo
Willems who is now the biggest
children's book author on Earth had
started he was one ahead of us and had
started an improv group and a sketch
group at NYU and I joined that and
um then uh there was a new group that
Todd hollaback Todd hollaback was in our
group and he decided we decided that we
didn't want to let new freshmen into our
group so Todd decided instead to start
like a B team at JV Squad and he left to
start a new group and that was like an
open meeting anyone who wants to be part
of this new sketch comedy group uh that
was like an offshoot of our main group
The steriliac could do it and then that
became the state that was the group that
you know in ever the main people from
the state Michael Showalter and Carrie
Kenny and Tomlin they all just showed up
there and uh that became the that was
like the Freshman B Team group and then
when it became clear to me and pretty
much everyone that that group was what
was really special
um our main senior group sort of
dissolved and I begged to be part of
this the new really yeah was there a lot
of people that got were there at first
but they kind of were weeded out because
they they just weren't funny there were
some yeah but it was shocking how much
of the main Core group was still the
same you know the state never officially
disbanded we're still a group it's 11 of
us and this is now 30 plus years later
and and it's the same core do you think
you'll ever get together again to do
something yeah we do we talk about it
actually quite regularly and we've we've
done we have done we have reunited with
and written new material for certain
live shows we've done uh over the years
and you know we're all still friends and
we all still recognize how special it
was and we are always talking about
Brewing something I see how supportive
you are I was at Joe the truglio's
screening for his film his horror movie
great and you were there supporting and
Michael Jan was there Camarino was there
and it was nice to see after all these
years you guys still support each I mean
not just that we went over to his house
when he was editing and we like helped
gave him notes notes like and we always
it's really great to have uh you know a
core of people that you have each
other's backs even though we've all
obviously gone in various different
directions and pursued different Avenues
and worked with different people but you
have sort of like a family that you came
from and it's really nice do you try to
cast those guys or your close friends it
seems like you do obviously in in just
about everything you do if you can if
it's right yeah I mean I have over the
years
um done that did they ever get mad when
you're like what happened to my audition
what about me yeah totally do they ever
say anything to you sure I mean you know
that it's it's a double-edged sword like
we in our movie The 10 we tried to cast
every single person in the state and you
and Ken wrote that yeah me and Ken yeah
and we did uh give everybody a part but
you know that's like sometimes you know
when you try to make it a thing and then
it's like it it it's you know how
casting is you never know
it's it's hard when you have to have a
mandate about casting yeah um no matter
what and but uh it has definitely been a
thing where we try to bring in
or or we end up bringing it a lot of
times
for example in another movie Wanderlust
we had this part
um of this guy who's a naked guy running
around the this commune and we
auditioned all sorts of different actors
who were great and like different types
and really funny did you audition them
naked some of them did What Would un
asked claiman and and solicited they
fully take their clothes off saw their
penis it was crazy did you love it I
mean I mean love it as in like like that
they took the risk not that you love
their dogs I love the memory that that
happened but no I was not loving that I
would rather than not do that I'm like
you we can if we get to there we'll look
at you yeah we don't have to do that
right now
um any big ones by the way yeah there
was some big dogs there were some big
ones yeah I bet they stretched it and
put warm water on it I mean it's hard
for me to have any because I I have like
the biggest penis
um
but uh anyway the point about that was
that we at the end of the day as we were
trying to figure out how to who's gonna
really nail this we were just like oh
let's just get Joe and then like Angelo
Julio came in and was like the greatest
thing you know like sometimes
for me the luckiest thing about me is
for my taste these are some of the
funniest people I've ever met and never
will meet and like you know
it it just happens that we all knew each
other in college so great why not when
you were doing the state in your mind
you recall saying this guy is going to
be a star were there anybody in the
state or where did you just saying
everybody here is going to be but who
was the guy or the girl that you were
like they are going to make it in
Hollywood well as I mentioned I wasn't
in the group originally so I got to see
their first show which was like
literally freshman at NYU in a little
black box theater doing some skits that
they wrote but I was like holy [__] and
when I think I I think Michael Black
stood out to me first I was like this
guy is so funny oh my God so funny but
then very quickly I I clocked them all
Michael Showalter and Carrie Kenny I was
just like Jesus these guys are really
funny you know